hey oh my god
welcome back to motherflippin minecraft
look at them go
look at my beats grow i think i mean i'm
making too many beats other melons
my automatic system for life what is
that
a wolf willis coming in too
i will never have to play the game ever
again i can just look at all the stuff
it's so satisfying dude oh man i'm so
happy
yeah look at all my automatic wool so
good
some of you thought i lost my hoe uh
because i put it in the system but i
it came through it just took a little
longer and i don't know why but yeah
you may notice some differences i put it
like a little temple up there
uh change the color of the beacons looks
so
[ __ ] cool at night unbelievable it
looks i didn't want to make this a
japanese style but it kind of came like
naturally it sort of reminds me of the
fire
nation in avatar i like it got this like
evil factory [ __ ] to go and i'll show
you later when it gets darker
it's really [ __ ] cool i should
probably trade someone said that
i don't have an overflow in this system
so that in case it fills up it should it
might
break it i don't know if that's true i'm
gonna assume yes
until i figured it out i should probably
just like trade up all my stuff
let me heal my pickaxe accident actually
get it thank you
definitely intended goddamn beach farm
training i'm on dwight schrute over here
all right we're good god damn it's so
laggy in my base now
oh yeah i got the the nether blocks i
was testing it out and i think it looks
pretty cool
i don't know if it's too much or too
little i haven't i haven't committed
like i haven't done
all the way around it right now it looks
like the homer simpson meme
uh if there's one thing i need to empty
it's definitely melon actually [ __ ] that
i just realized
once it's done it's gonna be pretty sick
i think yeah look at all the melons
coming through my melon crusher is
unbelievably strong
that's connected to the system too [ __ ]
i'm such a nerd dude it's disgusting
oh i connected my iron too so that
should be coming in i actually haven't
checked that that actually works or not
i just assumed because that's how large
my yeah it's working it only works
though if i'm close to it that's the
problem that's why i don't get as much
which is a god damn shame someone said
you can get a chunk loader or some [ __ ]
like that
i don't know how that works i can
download a mod or something to do it
here's my melon farm it's not my design
i don't know who made it i'll link in
the description because i highly
recommend it this is
effective as [ __ ] basically you just
need a cup i don't know i don't even
need those hoppers
yeah i use i use less hoppers than what
he said you should use
and it works totally fine with with six
you just have a
minecart hopper underneath collecting
all the all the melon that falls on top
and it's super simple it's literally
just like this
i think it's nine by nine nine by ten
yeah there you go and it shoots away
into my pump
absolute killer now that is dark i can
show off my
area i have not lit this place up yet so
i i'm a little
scared of showing i'm just climbing my
melons here
god damn them look at that so
[ __ ] cool oh i'm so pleased it's
gonna look sick with all the beacons up
too
once i get killed all the withers yeah
creepers are spawning i'm
adios so i have a way up but i also have
a way down now i didn't have a way down
uh let's see it's my bed bonky's still
there still
chilling yeah my bed kind of sucks i i
built
i built this i saw this on instagram i'm
like yeah it looks cool i guess i'll
build it
uh and i'm like oh [ __ ] i need to put my
bed somewhere
shut up shut
i had to move her pool you will be
dropped in water soon don't you worry
oh maybe i can put uh the cat by the uh
no no no don't run don't run don't jump
do not jump i need you alive
don't end your existence please please
please please please please please
please stop it don't jump don't jump
it's it's a life worth living trust me
is it
for you have a full life of torture
ahead of you here come here
come here yeah get in the water get in
the water you dumb little cow
get in the water get in the water get in
the water where you belong
get in the water where you belong you're
a stinker you need to bathe
come on come on
there you go that's where you belong you
dirty criminal
i'm on to you bonky supervised damn you
look holy in this line look at this
oh so poetic look at this
uh yeah i can just drop down here ow
ow why did that not work
oh my legs that i don't have
let me check this again what the hell
just happened
oh why do i take damage
so i actually said it wrong i have four
uh
inputs not just two so it's really fast
uh no one cares felix okay that's good
good good i'm glad because i have my uh
in here it's my smelter room
and it's where i made all the brick and
i like that and here's my nether right
farm
is it called neither right no it's
called the nether wart
sorry brain so small got a six pack you
can make automatic
nether wart farm but they're not afk
automatic
which kind of fits the whole purpose of
my factory i would love to make one
otherwise but uh
if you anyone knows how to make a fully
automatic where you're not sitting
in the mine cart collecting stuff let me
know i really wish minecraft more than
anything would add so dispensers or and
i could plant stuff
that would just make me really really
happy but yeah i'm surprised not more
people use the nether brick because it
looks
sick it looks so cool in red and all you
need is nether wart and nether brick
oh you know what would be cool i just
realized oh my god i can't believe i
didn't think of this
hey how you doing he's trapped there
homie's just chilling don't worry about
it so i have this automatic smelter
right
you see where i'm going with this so
here's where i melt the
nether right the nether [ __ ] it's called
nether brick
i guess the edges doesn't work i don't
know why
maybe i need to extend it for that to
work probably it doesn't matter it works
fine
but the the input goes in here into this
chest but it would be
way cooler if the input goes back into
my system
so whatever i smelt just goes back into
oh my god that's so [ __ ] cool
oh that's gonna be the bomb yeah wait
how would i connect that
i mean yeah that would be super easy
because it just has to connect uh over
here
where see i have four signals why are
they all lit up
that's weird is it not working what the
[ __ ] happened
oh maybe i can't have four yeah maybe i
can't have four
oh sad noises see why is this lit up
stop it there you go what the [ __ ]
go forth my children to victory
to victory satisfaction
now today i thought it's about god damn
time that i try and find a stronghold
to try and beat the dragon usually they
can be quite far away
good night good night bonky bunky my
donkey
i like to bonk that donkey if you know
what i mean all right let's see if i can
jump without dying
oh my god what is hurting me it's fine
i'm fully stacked near the right i don't
i don't need i don't need a jump down
system all right i need to find bonky
there you are that's a sweet ass
so [ __ ] snake bonky
bucky loves melons what we need to do is
uh throw the eye of enders to see where
the stronghold is right
that way funky funky you saw it which
why am i not picking them up hello is it
lagging
what's happening whoa mega lag
i don't know if it's a good idea to
bring bonky or not because i have a lot
of water
sorry bonkey you can't come on this
mission
all right and we're off gamers the
journey's on
we're at the end game now fellas it's
been a long journey
damn it looks so [ __ ] sick i just
built it from brain
not to flex or anything i mean don't
look at the back don't don't
don't look at the back of it look how
good it look
all right i really should build bridges
across so i can take bunkie with me
yeah yeah i should do that build bridges
across the lanes
hopefully it's not too far away let's do
a throw
oh my god it's so laggy nice
so this way all right
we go by land we go by foot we go by
boat now
hey who knows maybe we'll find some new
cool epic stuff on the way right
like a dog that'd be sick instead of
bunnies
everywhere just [ __ ] bunnies
just die just die bro just die bro just
die bro just die bro
bro just die bro bro bro you're not
gonna live you're not gonna live told
you bro you should have just done
it sorry all bunnies that are watching
wouldn't it be so ironic if i just die
from a [ __ ] sand trap or something
like that not gonna happen the sand
would be too scared
it would just move away look i ain't
afraid
completely unfazed
nothing can stop me oh you get scared
sociopathic all right here we go damn it
looks so cool with the shaders
hey look at that oh okay this is
definitely a death trap
yeah yeah if i hit that i would have
fallen not even gonna meme it
oh [ __ ] i probably would have made it as
long as i don't suffocate
well plus i would have pulled out the
bed dream style last second clutch
no problem all right we're off the deep
end
it's just me in the ocean now i sure
wish i had my donkey with me
or my mule well this is how it goes this
is the swamp i guess we can pluck some
flowers from my main [ __ ] i definitely
been here before i recognize this place
so beautiful i can't believe all the
hours i sunk into minecraft i still
really enjoy it right right cow we gotta
go through the forest
oh [ __ ] credit [ __ ] uh here's a
terrible place to throw but
i don't know maybe i can get up on this
let's get up on the trees and then we'll
do another throw
whoa we passed it or am i either i'm
walking in the wrong way
i crushed oh that's good that's not too
far away then
i hope so oh i also have a question is
there any other other fully automatic
farms that i can make
i don't need food because i have the
carrots
gold farm maybe is that fully automatic
god damn it not on the tree please i
brokey
what's that sunset it's a nicer biome
what's up cow living life to the fullest
[Music]
try living life to the i'm hitting him
with a shovel
hey don't zigzag me [ __ ] i kill you
with a
shovel okay maybe i was just walking the
wrong way
why is it taking me here now i was so
excited that i had walked past it but i
think i just walked the wrong way
when i played with the friends i had to
walk like 8 000 steps or something
i would prefer not to do that not gonna
lie
i feel like it's changing direction am i
going in circles i swear to god i
what is happening that is definitely
going back okay we found it
did that just where did that go so it's
here
it's literally here well boys
it's mother flipping digging time
because i mine all day or mine all night
should we speedrun this
seriously my heart will be in pieces if
i lose this world
let's not take it for granted now you
never know what i remember the
stronghold being
strong that makes sense right yeah but
i'm stronger
faster smarter epic air
batticer sexicer full inventoricer
oh also there there's a new caves update
coming out uh you probably probably know
about that already but
they're making the game deeper there's
areas underneath
bedrock now bedrock is lower which is
super exciting
i can't wait they got axolotls coming up
a lot of cool stuff in the new update
honestly as exciting as the
the bees are i mean don't mean to be
like that but
this is what the people wanted and they
listen now where the is this stronghold
oh that's bedrock what if we keep
digging this way
well i guess i'll never be a speedrunner
what the f is this
oh my gosh i feel like i'm where
there we go
wait wait a minute it's a spawner
what what are the [ __ ] odds
what zombie spawner sweet
name tag yeah i'll take it that's a
really garbage loot for a spawner
we try to find a stronghold but we found
gold
well there's still zombies
holy moly smackaroney
are they are they just like stuck in the
corner
oh pathetic
okay oh what does that sound so spoopy
all right this is not what i want
what happens if i throw this inside oh
it was through the wall amazing well it
looks like it's going upward
maybe i dug too much down oh there it is
what up gamers
[Applause]
that's the fastest fish that i've ever
seen i am a speed runner
i am a speedrunner oh my god dude
all right that's [ __ ] hilarious let's
get rid of this
lava all right pivotal moment
for every minecrafter
whoa let's make sure we don't fall down
oh my gosh dude
i mean i could probably kill him
honestly honestly i could probably
[ __ ] do it right
i got should i
let me pee and think about it oh they
might my camera froze
alright gamers i'm back i should
probably set up a portal first
before i go through hi friends
well i guess we're not friends then
yeah see there's a lot of loot in here
as well i forgot about that
look at that apples guys look at them
apples
dude i'm too rich i am just too [ __ ]
rich
i don't i don't remember them being
doors and stuff oh gosh i'm locked out
what a trouble
whoa hello yeah that's the problem with
these they're
kind of a maze and not the good kind of
maze
uh yeah let me just set up a portal i'll
set up a portal
that's gorgeous
gosh i i don't know how but like
my seed is just filled with this
red forest bat i never
ever ever found the blue one and i don't
know how that's impossible
oh we're really close okay we just need
to go
that way yeah look at that we're super
close
no [ __ ] way oh i know exactly where
ah
dyson autotune
stay away from me child
what'd i tell you child now you paid the
price
made everything else looks so goddamn
pretty i'm not gonna stop here
oh my god where's the entrance it's on
the other side
but like so close but so far away
all right home sweet home
think i'd see this place in a while i'm
not gonna lie
funky monkey my man i'm back
i missed you man hey i found the
stronghold and guess what in the next
episode stop kissing me i know
me we're gonna fight the dragon and i'm
gonna bring
bonkey with me he's got a personal beef
to set
anyway gamers that's it for this episode
smash a like if you're excited for the
finale and i'll see you
next time thanks for watching bro-face